[Aplausos]
cometemos tres errores el primero es
infravalorar la cantidad de información
que producimos cada día el segundo es
despreciar el valor de esa información y
el tercero es pensar que nuestro
principal problema es una agencia
distante y super poderosa que se llama n
seã y es verdad que la n sea tiene el
mayor acceso los mejores recursos las
mejores herramientas pero no les hace
falta nada de eso para espiarnos a
nosotros porque nosotros lo tenemos todo
ahí vivimos en casas de cristal
este es malte spitz es miembro del
partido verde alemán y en 2009 malte le
pidió a su compañía telefónica que le
mandara todos los datos que tenían sobre
él y la deutsche telekom que era su
compañía le dijo que no dos demandas más
tarde le mandaron un cedé con un excel
de 30 mil 832 líneas como 'guerra y paz'
pero tres veces este documento
interminable comprende desde septiembre
de 2009 hasta febrero de 2010 tiene
exactamente seis meses y no es casual
tienen seis meses porque en verano de
2008 la unión europea presentó la
directiva de retención de datos donde se
exige que cada compañía telefónica con
más de 10.000 clientes guarde los datos
de todos sus clientes durante un mínimo
de seis meses y un máximo de dos años
amante le dieron seis meses como
diciendo esto es todo lo que tenemos
porque nos obliga la ley probablemente
le deben un año y medio de esmalte que
no podía leer máquina se lo mandó a un
semanario que a su vez contactó con una
agencia de visualización de datos para
hacer algo con esto entonces ellos
cogieron estos datos de deutsche telekom
otros datos de malte que eran públicos
como por ejemplo de su cuenta de twitter
o de su blog y con esto hicieron este
mapa que estáis viendo ahora que más que
un mapa es como un diario
automático y terrorífico de la vida de
malte podemos ver cuando va en tren que
es lo que está haciendo ahora mismo
cuando se para donde se queda cuando va
como va cuánto tiempo está cuando está
comiendo cuando está durmiendo como
ahora mismo cuando coge un avión quién
le llama cuánto tiempo le llama quién le
manda mensajes qué mensajes lo vemos
todo
esto está en la web lo podéis ver el
motivo por el que pasa esto
es que mal te tiene un teléfono en el
bolsillo que cada cinco minutos hace un
ping aplasten a que tenga master que le
dice tienes algo para mí tengo algún
correo tengo algún mensaje de whatsapp
ha pasado algo en el mundo
levantar la mano los que tenéis un
teléfono en el bolsillo que hace lo
mismo
entonces nuestros teléfonos cada cinco
minutos se están diciendo estoy aquí
estoy aquí ahora estoy aquí oye que
estoy aquí y esto es lo que pasa y esto
no tiene precedentes esto no lo teníamos
antes el equivalente directo es esto que
tenéis ahora en la pantalla esto es el
perfil de una persona vigilada por la
stasi durante años
es como una servilleta con 46 post-its
hay que incluyen a su tía el lechero el
cura de su parroquia esto son cinco
minutos en la vida de malte spitz y esta
información es automática y lo peor es
que esto es sólo la información sobre
mante pero mante está rodeado de gente
con nosotros con teléfonos como el suyo
que están produciendo la misma
información y esa compañía los ve todos
este es una foto de mi compañero juanjo
sánchez es una foto del 15m
pero vamos a verla desde el punto de
vista de las telecomunicaciones esta
plaza está llena de móviles y con esos
móviles podemos saber exactamente quién
está en la plaza casi como si pusiéramos
un cordón alrededor con nombres y
apellidos y no solo sabemos cuándo han
venido de dónde han venido con quién
vienen con quién se van a quién llaman
lo sabemos todo sobre ellos sabemos
incluso si están en el cuarto piso o
están abajo en la plaza
esto es como ve esa foto un algoritmo de
análisis de tráfico y aquí ya empezamos
a ver un poco cosas chulas no vemos que
no toda la gente que está en la plaza
es igual hay gente más importante que
otra entonces si tenemos controles sobre
estas digamos telecomunicaciones sobre
esta red podemos hacer cosas como por
ejemplo apagar los nodos de esta plaza
es decir aislar a las personas que
reúnen a todos los demás de todos los
demás también podemos hacer lo que hizo
el gobierno de ucrania hace año y medio
y mandarles un mensaje que ponga
queridos usuarios ha sido usted
registrado como participe en una
manifestación ilegal masiva
no nos comportamos igual cuando sabemos
que nos vigilan desde jeremy bentham
sabemos que la mejor manera de vigilar a
una población es que nos sepan cuando
les están vigilando y cuando no a marte
en esos seis meses le estaban vigilando
el 78 por ciento del tiempo
y estamos hablando solo de nuestros
móviles no estamos hablando ni de
nuestros ordenadores ni de las cámaras
que hay en la calle y en las tiendas y
en los escaparates y en los aeropuertos
y en los trenes y en donde quiera que
estemos y que no vemos no estamos
hablando de los radares de las
carreteras que registran más que si nos
pasamos de velocidad no estamos hablando
de lo que tenemos en la cartera cuantas
chips de identificación personal tenemos
en la cartera
tenemos muchos tenemos el dni y el
carnet de conducir o el abono transporte
tenemos la tarjeta de crédito de débito
de puntos la tarjeta de puntos del
supermercado hace 20 años la base de
datos personal más grande del mundo no
la tenía la enee sea y no la tenía la
estancia y pobrecita la tenía walmart la
cadena de supermercados estadounidenses
porque porque cuando te dan una tarjeta
de puntos tú lo que estás haciendo es
decirle a una empresa quién eres dónde
vives cuánto ganas en que te lo gastas
que comes cuántos hijos tienes cuándo te
vas de vacaciones cuando te pones
enfermo y todo con la esperanza de que
dentro de seis meses o de un año si te
gastas mucho dinero te dan un tupper
y no es distinto de lo que hacemos en la
red porque doy que telecom es una
empresa legítima y europea que tiene que
obedecer la ley de protección de datos
igual que telefónica telefónica aquí
tiene que obedecer leyes de protección
de datos pero las empresas no es lo
mismo con las empresas que nos hacen los
móviles que nos hacen los sistemas
operativos que nos ofrecen correos
gratuitos que nos dan esas apps que nos
bajamos y que nos piden permiso para un
montón de cosas raras y decimos para
algo lo que eran
lo quieren para venderlo
para qué quieres angry birds tener
acceso a tu gps para hacer dinero
a nuestros vigilantes no les importa que
no seamos nadie que no seamos
importantes porque son algoritmos no son
personas y nuestro perfil es automático
existe aunque nadie lo mire y el día que
alguien lo mire y te cambia la suerte tu
perfil tu historial se convierte en tus
antecedentes
puedes acabar atascado en el aeropuerto
de uno de los 75 países donde ser
homosexual es ilegal o puedes acabar en
un país donde echarle una foto a una
farmacia de producción masiva desde el
otro lado de la carretera es terrorismo
esto pasa en eeuu o puedes acabar en
siria donde le pegan tiros a la gente en
la calle activistas periodistas
especialmente puedes acabar en mexico df
donde los zetas tienen acceso a la
información de las telefónicas para ver
quién contacta con la policía y
cortarles la cabeza
hay mil maneras de estar en el sitio
equivocado en el momento equivocado y a
veces ni siquiera te tienes que mover
en holanda tenían un censo y era un
censo que incluía religiones con la
mejor intención del mundo querían saber
cuántos protestantes cuántos católicos y
cuántos judíos tenían para saber cuánto
dinero tenían que poner en cada
comunidad en cada iglesia o sinagoga qué
pasa que cuando llegaron los nazis ya
tenían los deberes hechos sólo el 10 por
ciento de los judíos holandeses
sobrevivieron a la 2ª guerra mundial si
esa base de datos no existiera la cifra
había sido muy distinta
lo que quiero decir es que nuestro
problema no es la n sea y no son los
gobiernos corruptos no son las compañías
ambiciosas que quieren vender nuestros
datos y no son las personas malas y no
tiene nada que ver ni con sus
intenciones ni con sus malas intenciones
el problema es que la existencia misma
de esa información nos hace vulnerables
de maneras que no podemos ni anticipar
ahora mismo
tenemos que poner cortinas en nuestras
casas no podemos esperar a que nos las
pongan por fuera tenemos que ponerlas ya
tenemos que empezar a usar criptografía
en nuestros móviles en nuestras
comunicaciones en nuestros ordenadores
empezar a pensar lo bien cada vez que
alguien nos ofrece una tarjeta de puntos
y decir
no sólo por nosotros porque además este
estado de vigilancia es una de las
peores enfermedades que tiene una
democracia así que os convidó a llegar a
casa empezar a usar todo
y si alguien quiere ver lo que estáis
haciendo que pida una orden de registro
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]